true story is not a myth the name of the
game is to play or be played on
andre last night gorgeous dre you get
him yet
no i'm not
you know him no i don't
you don't know gorgeous dre
he was in pimp's up holds down the one
that went to jail oh yeah yeah i
remember i was winning last night we
were talking about
how you know how we had to sleep in the
cars and
eat bananas for dinner and [ __ ]
you know people don't know
you know the real breaks if you think
it's easy you know then you you ain't
really been through nothing you ain't
really pimping
you know unless you really have bad
breaks we call it you know
ups and downs yeah
how'd you get started ron
um
well i got started when i was uh you
know
15 16 years old
um i always liked the dress
and i remember i was in high school and
i had a
69 sadandeville and i always wore suits
and i met this young lady in school she
had a 68 cooperville cadillac
and i got to reading donald donald going
books icebergs slims and i went to jail
and uh those books inspired me
you know to to to do this
and you know i i don't want to say a
pimp is uh turned out to be be a pimp i
think it always have to be in them
you know i think it was something that
was born in me and not nothing i had to
practice or really get from the book
what the book did is um confirm it was
my confirmation that that's what i
wanted to do you recognized you had
those qualities exactly
exactly
yeah you you have something in your
makeup and your character that allows
you to
do this and
succeed at it right and and and this is
it i promise you it's not easy
it's not easy see see um
and and as far as the difference between
the pimp and the dope dealer
uh the dope sell itself you know pimping
you have to have knowledge you have to
have uh inspiration and guidance to
to attract the woman who wants to do it
and i think sometimes most times the
women already have it in them but a
certain pimp can bring it out of them
and enhance something that they wanted
to do all along
did you see it before you were 15 i mean
i had an idea i had a clue i wasn't
clueless i had a clue
and then when when i saw the life
um
and eventually i got exposure
that's what i really wanted to do
you know it was like uh
pimp or die
um
i
i believed in god but the god i believed
and then was the pimp god
tell me about your mom and dad
well my mom
my father i never really had a father
because i'm from uh upstate new york my
father lived in jersey
and um he never came to any of my events
never supported me when i played
football when i was in the soapbox derby
never came around
and then when i got into the game i was
going up to uh newark new jersey he was
over in trenton
and he came over to see me because i was
on top of my game and uh
like so many words he was proud of me
that his son was
a
big time pimp
and i guess that inspired him to wants
to build a relationship with me
but my mom my mom detested pimping she
was totally against it
um she wanted me to
go to school and get a job and have a
401k and a pension
and uh i actually thought that i was
going to die
in the game like i said only god i
believed in was the pimp god at that
time so my mom was totally against it
you know she wanted me to work and get a
401k
and i told her work wasn't meant for
everybody
you know if i was working i thought that
a person that worked
actually had a job i thought something
was mentally wrong with them
i thought something was mentally wrong
you working
um
you know because i didn't have the
proper education i got a ged and i got
that from prison
um in 1988
i think i got that that ged so you know
i disqualified myself to to get a job
buried in prison for
uh it was grand largely a fortunate
deception
like a con game so you're always kind of
your life was in the streets from an
early age yeah yeah yeah yeah and
pimping just became a more
respectable or just the avenue that you
chose
right uh actually it started when i was
a shoe shine i would shoeshine when i
was 10 years old
so by me shining shoes has allowed me to
go around be around the pimps and seeing
the flashy clothes and the jewelry
and you know i was born in the hood in
in in uh
and you know i got certain um
pointers from certain guys that was
already exposed to the
pimping game
i remember when i was i call it
shoplifting stealing game i would go to
a
already seasoned pimp and say something
like out of line so they can correct me
i would say hey man you know i got this
little turnout uh i sent her to work 12
o'clock at night
so now i don't know if that's correct or
not
so they'll say no man man i put my bra
down at such and such time 12 o'clock at
night the ship's almost over with so i
would say something that i don't know
which i would call out of pocket so the
older pimps can correct me so i call
that shoplifting still in game
[Music]
how many girls do you have oh
the most i had was eight at one time
i was going to
springfield massachusetts
and um it's a handful
i'm sorry eight girls is a handful yeah
yeah but it was um
i had i had taught them how to get along
like family
you know like they say one bad apple can
spoil a bunch
well if i had one that had anna marcinia
jealousy against another one i would
take her to the side separate her and
tell her how it's not benefiting me or
you
so i would teach them how to get along
with one another
you know whatever the problem is we're
going to fix it right now
so yeah it was a handful sometime but
all they did just needed some correction
the game has changed over the years
no no i totally disagree with that
really yeah i totally disagree i'd love
to hear your thoughts on that um
to me the game never changed
okay so the players have changed exactly
that's what i mean exactly the game will
never change
like yourself are still doing it the
same way exactly but then there are
these new guys that come from the gang
background that are doing it
right very very different i call it
violating they violating the game yeah
they're violating they're using things
like intimidation drugs things like that
yeah well that brings on a large to me
because uh the same way you get a get a
chick abroad the same way you get it the
same way you got to keep her
you know and then somebody else can come
around with the same mentality that you
have and
a little sharper a little meaner then
they can knock you for your bra you
understand so i never try to keep get
abroad on the sex tip
never try to keep them on the sex steps
because you got somebody that can out
screw you
screw longer than you you know the
pimping is a mind game you know a mind
game brock can go have a sex six seven
times tonight you understand so you
think what you're doing making her uh uh
climax you think you're doing something
that's no that that ain't nothing you
know you gotta you gotta get that mind
you gotta get that man you got the mind
everything else will follow
everything else will follow
so i i was going to springfield
massachusetts i'd never forget i had um
one chick
and uh
and i made a mistake
and helped injured her her leg so we got
to springfield massachusetts she was on
crutches
but she still went to work
and
in about 30 days
about 30 days she got well and before
you know what i had i was eight deep
i was eight deep so i moved out of the
motel moved out of the motel
i got an apartment downtown springfield
massachusetts and i bought a house in
west springfield massachusetts
and i was able to go to a
cadillac dealer and i ordered a triple
white fleetwood
and that's just
because i had the one chick
on crutches
and my desire and motivation
to do better
see i always thought one one broad was
too close to none
you know the more the merrier one was
too close to none and i didn't believe
in putting my hands on them
chastising them because
um
no you are you gonna beat your broad up
why you gonna beat her up and then she
gonna
be injured she's gonna be wounded and
you're gonna send her to work like that
you you hurting your product
so you you you gotta with that mind a
woman can stay in pain okay any ain't no
such thing as a certain amount of pain
man you can beat a woman and be the one
it's the same thing like how you think
women can stand out in the cold 30 below
zero with a short skirt on
and flip-flops you understand so they
can endure a lot of pain whooping them
ain't nothing to them you know you got
to get that mind you get the mind i
remember one girl i i had um i
threatened her to fire her
and what i mean by that i told her
like you ain't doing right you ain't you
you you're not producing right i say you
got to go
instead of beating her and try to make
her get more money i think you got to go
so i grabbed all the clothes threw him
in the car and started driving towards
the airport now i really wasn't trying
to let her go but i made her think that
she got to go and finally fire you
you're going to the airport you're going
home you're going to get the f away from
me i want nothing else to do with you
and on her way to the airport she's vow
that she's going to get it right and
she's going to get in pocket and she's
going to make that money right
so if i was whooping abroad it ain't
necessary
you didn't ever say so so the game to me
the game would never change
players change
you got to get chose you got to get
chosen with money you know saying you
can't get choked with a promise
and and then uh me and phil [ __ ] was
talking about this last night that if
i knocked somebody for they brawl and
they got a bail money on it right
uh i'm gonna give you give me the
receipt i'm gonna give your bail money
you know i'm not gonna take you abroad
and and lead town and you gotta bail up
on her you understand
nowadays these dudes you you don't bail
the broad out and they don't got the
broad and gone and don't care nothing
about your bail money and none of that
you know so
the game will never change the rules
will never change they always stay the
same
tell me about the the type of girl type
of woman that you will
kind of bring bring into this life
uh woman's that um
that's smart
i didn't i didn't tolerate that getting
high i didn't play that get high
drinking and stuff while you're working
because any kind of high does your
thinking
and you got to be fully alert
you gotta be fully alert out there
because the trick can come kill you you
get hit by a car somebody put something
in your drink you know you you know i
you know they just smoke weed or
whatever after they work but i didn't
play that before you get work because i
want you to be shocked and fully aware
before you go to work
i've heard it explained from other pimps
that you don't want a girl that you like
you want a girl who likes you exactly
and that was oh man because you can you
go after broad that that that you like
she could have lost me
she could really don't like you
and and but you done fell in love with
her let her violate the game bring you
any kind of nonsense poison your stable
because you like her you don't want her
to leave so you're going to tolerate
something from sally when betty trying
to be with you but sally violating you
and your rules now so betty thinks she
can do the same thing
you understand so so when you you you
get abroad that that you like don't like
you
uh it can be some larceny there from a
previous relationship or or or with
another pimp then she could bring
another larceny and animosity towards
you
because she don't like you you like her
so i really believe that you know i i
want somebody to like me
you don't sound like me and don't don't
and don't don't want to be with nobody
else but me
how many girls you have now
um
i don't try to count i don't try to
count girls i try to count money
and and i want to get to the point to
where um
i want to be able to measure money and
not count and put it on the scale and
tell you how much it is
you know um
now when you and backing up a little bit
when you said uh
uh the the game changed you have pims
out there selling dope now oh yeah you
have turns out they're sounding dope
they get mad at me because i call them
out you know you you know you're a dope
dealer
it don't take a rocket science just to
to sell no dough all you got to do is
open your hand don't sell itself
but anybody can't do this pimping
anybody can't do it
you know this this here is is one of the
hard to me one of the hardest things to
do
because you're not accepted by society
you know then you're the scum of the
earth you guys get crucified exactly on
my channel exactly you you just come
into earth
other pyramids is not crazy about you
because you're a threat to them and
they're stable you're a threat to them
you understand
so other brawls ain't crazy about you
because they're crazy about you they
will be with you
you understand
so and another thing
when when
when i i call it interviewing a lady i
need to know everything about her
i want to know if you ever put somebody
in jail before
i want to know what happens if you get
under pressure would you sign state
evidence would you tell have you ever
told anybody on anybody
do you have an uncle or your father on a
police force
okay i need to know these things i need
to know are you on any kind of uh
medication depression medication or do
you take medicine what kind of medicine
do you take
okay have you ever killed anybody have
you ever tried to poison anybody
you don't say i need to know these
things about it's like i need to know
abroad before i send them to work i want
to know everything i can about you
you know i just just i just never
accepted any and everybody you know it's
certain criterias and qualifications
you know all money ain't good money
all money and good money
how has technology impacted what you do
oh it's it's it's
i said i'd never be a hater but i'm a
hater about this here because when i
first started we didn't even have pages
we had to use a pay phone and then we
got pages and uh man we thought we had
it going on when we got pages you
understand and so now man technology
today man they got that back page thing
they use computers broads got cell
phones i mean it's like these dudes got
it easy today man
you know when when you know back in the
day when we go to check the track man we
got to ride up and down the track try to
find our broad hoping praying that she's
still around you know we gotta ride the
blade we gotta make sure she okay but
now all you do you can send a text
message what you have
how much you got or whatever whatever
but you know and another thing about
checking abroad how much he got we
we call it mexican pimping soon she
turned to date you holding your hand out
you give me my money at the end of the
night i don't need to go mexican pimp
every time she turn to date you no no no
no and then another thing i don't i
wouldn't like to be caught up in the
same perimeter of of of my girl you know
for whatever reason you understand uh
somebody built an occasion and they now
they got pictures of you and the girl or
or corresponding with one another in the
same vicinity all the time then you know
that's that's evidence against you so i
would never try to be caught in public
or on the track talking to abroad
never you're out of rochester new york
out of rochester upstate new york
but i left rochester in uh
in
1774 i left rochester i went up to uh
montreal canada matter of fact i was in
montreal when the olympics was up there
when sugar ray leonard was uh
had just started boxing
um i had left rochester because
rochester was small
and i had a lot of haters there and had
a lot of haters so
uh
like
uh virgil chicago crew
these guys i grew up with you understand
i grew up with these cats in the streets
so
uh anytime they have an event you know
because i try to show up
you know
um because i grew up these these cats
are like my brothers
you know i mean we have so much in
common then then then you know i'm not
hating on the new guys that's coming up
but i got more in common with i call
them predecessors who who paved the way
for them young cats you understand
and
and
and and and i got to be honest the cats
give us our props they give us they give
credit where credit do you know just
that when we come around me and virgil
uh k red and us when we come around them
young cats they they like back up
because like you're saying when i first
came in they're still in game they're
absorbing it's like it's like a secret
society exactly exactly
it's like a cult it's like a cult secret
society
yeah but it's it's it's lonely at the
top it's a very lonely game because i
think society don't don't accept you you
understand uh uh who who gonna accept me
dressed like this here on the monday
yeah uh uh uh and then the way you make
a living exactly that just makes exactly
and i got nice cars in the driveway and
they they randomly leave uh i'm not
working nowhere they randomly leave and
or they'll see me waxing the car i
remember one time i was down in um
painted post new york up there i buy
corning new york
uh i had was standing in this
condominium
and uh
it was expensive
and uh i didn't know until later on
there's a lot of doctors lawyers police
lived in those condominiums
so here it is i got a
new cadillac and the new lincoln and uh
all the cars going to work my two cars
the only cars in the parking lot every
day all day my car disappeared at night
yes that
and so what happened was um
so they started they thought i was a
dope dealer and uh so they put nuts i
put notes on my windshield
and uh so
i need a kilo cocaine meet me at earn
that mall whatever
uh how much you're going to charge me
for a key so you know it start it got
annoying
and so i called the police and said
listen man somebody keep putting these
notes on my cards and it's getting
annoying and and i'm getting offended by
it
so the police said next time you get a
note of your car bring the note to the
police station the police station was
like three blocks from my house
so i drove got the car drove to the
police station and gave him a note say
say here this is the kind of notes i
could get
police said uh mr gardner how did you
get here i said uh i drove i live right
on the corner they say you drove i said
yeah they say you're under arrest for
driving with suspended license
so they all they knew all along that my
license was suspended
and so they they it was like a
punk-ass uh entrapment
yeah and i laughed about that today
so
typically a girl will come to you for
representation or you will search her
out and and get her to oh
yeah no i would i would check out look
at her and uh
a lot of people think that pimps are
forcing the girls to do this oh
absolutely not
absolutely not um
if i gotta put my hands on on a woman i
don't need them man
no you you you you roll up on the broad
you see you know they they reckless
eyeball they look at you you know you
check them out certain qualifications
quality that you see in them and you you
know you you feel something you know
what i mean
then you do what i call interview
you talk to them you find out where
they're at
you know they started talking like they
cooking for coca puff ain't got nothing
to do with you you understand
um pimping is one of the hardest cases
to prove
it's one of the harder cases to prove
but if you give a chick reasons and
ammunition ammunition and and and
and um
stuff to work with then you can get
jammed up
i i'd seen somebody was talking about
this last night um
you never wolf abroad and sent them to
work
you never went abroad and sent them to
work you sent them to work you're
sitting in the work with larceny in
their heart and they're not in a right
mind
so what what what you do if if you have
to check them
strongly check them
and now it's time for them to go to work
and if they can't tell you what they did
wrong then they shouldn't leave your
presence
because see before a woman leave my
presence i want to know i want you to
tell me what you did wrong
was you wrong
was i wrong for checking you
if she say what she did wasn't wrong
then she'll do it again
if she say i was wrong for checking her
she got larceny in her heart
so if she mad or get a drink in her and
mad at me if the police roll up on her
with the largest in her heart i'm
subject to catch a case
so now what i do if i'm checking abroad
and and and and see okay now do you know
what you did wrong she said yes i said
tell me how and why you did what you did
wrong she gave me a good explanation now
do you think i was wrong for checking
she said no he was right whatever
whatever cool now you can go back to
work
you go back to work now because i know
there's no locks in me there these women
are going to do this regardless of
whether they have a pimp or not
yeah but see here here here it is
because there are guys out there
shopping around for girls like them
right right but we call them renegades
we call them renegades i mean i'm trying
to find the source of it all the sources
but all are married men who are cheating
on their wives oh oh absolutely see
you you bring up a good point mark
you're just a manager yeah yeah and and
and and i teach my brothers how to talk
on any level any conversation but you're
a street manager so you look a certain
way you look different you act different
you do things a little differently than
a typical manager exactly somebody said
uh i'm a coochie coach
i'm a coochie yeah but but this the
demand for this exists oh absolutely
because you didn't you didn't create it
no the girl didn't create it no
we went with that without the married
guy who wouldn't be no problem the
married guy driving up and down the
street exactly see and and the reason
that they need to probably blame the
wife
exactly because they're not getting what
they want at home yeah they're saying
they're not getting what they want at
home listen listen man with the wife you
got the knack she got to tell you what
you did wrong what you did right why you
didn't pay this bill why you paid that
bill now you you probably can't get an
erection because you you arguing with
the wife about this and that with the
hooker man she ain't gonna do nothing
but love on you man and make you happy
get that thing up and get you to release
that pressure and you good you
understand you give her money you ain't
got to hear her nagging you ain't gotta
hear crying and bitching at you about
she's going off into the sunset and for
a reason that is a whole another
conversation these women can't really
handle their money very well oh see they
don't they don't have a motivation and i
experienced a good point
that's where you come in yeah i
experienced that in um
philadelphia pennsylvania i'm gonna have
my degree shortly yeah yeah i
experienced that game as we bought
bought. so i was in philadelphia and and
two of my girls i didn't know they was
missing but eventually i found out there
was music because i've had so many girls
and and and and i rolled up on it was
even 13th and locust in philadelphia and
i rolled up on them and it was like 1 30
1 30 at night 1 30 in the morning
whatever whatever
now by then you know
my girls probably have like
a nickel 1000 1500 you understand
but i rolled up on these chicks and you
know they they mine until i get a phone
call ain't nobody called me and say hey
man this chick don't chose whatever you
mind until i get that phone call so my
point is they was renegade and when i
roll up the check check the bank man i
think they had like seventy dollars a
piece
said another piece but she without a man
somebody to manage them seventy thousand
pizza is cool for them you understand
but with a manager somebody who's gonna
inspirate you and motivate you to get
that higher about money and show you
what what what 500 can do versus what 70
can do you understand
so you know i try to i try to i try to
make my brothers look better than any
broad on the track
when
when i buy gators i'm buying them gators
when i buy me they wearing meats
you know because there's an attraction i
want them to attract other women say man
that dude treats y'all good man
you know what i mean and then i have
them to try to bring other girls home
success breeds success exactly exactly
what would you say is the number one
thing that squares don't understand
about this life
other squares don't understand what
squares don't understand about this this
lifestyle oh absolutely not well a lot
of them
hate it man because you know like you
know you got this chick not only you can
sex her in any position any time you get
ready she's giving you money she giving
you bread man you know she
like romaine say eating popcorns out of
his toes you know you got broads just
filling all your fantasies man and the
squares can't get that they got to get
it they got they get the only way to get
they got to pay for it
you understand they got to pay for it
and um
like
some squares detest pimps
like at one time i detested a square
i did touch squares because i know you
didn't like me i know you didn't accept
me in your society
you understand i know you didn't accept
me in society so now we it's a mutual
agreement you don't like me and i don't
like you
i think there's a lot of envy
that exactly
and that that's that's even with the
pimp game too
and and and it's sickening man jealousy
to me is a disease
jealousy is a sickness
you know i want anybody that that's
doing whatever i'm doing i want them to
succeed
you understand because that's motivation
to me if you join me that you can buy
double eye rolls right you motivate me
that i can get a rolls royce you know
what i mean but one thing i had a
problem with is as far as envy when um
when when the dope boy try to mix up
with the pippin with selling dope you're
gonna sell don't sell dope
but don't blame me that you got the
money out the cop
you understand if you that's what you
did that's what you did cool i'm not
hating on you
but don't blame me that you you you
straight up pippin with this here don't
blame it on that do what you do bless
you do what you do
you know so it's it's uh
it's it's it's it's sad man like i said
any and everybody can't film you've been
in love before have you been in love
before have i been in love
hmm
i i want to say
that means no
the fact that takes this long well well
here it is mark i really really cared
for my women i really care i would have
died for my women and i don't know if
you call that love and i would that
might be more important than what most
people call love yeah i would i would
have died for them
meaning that
if i'm riding down the track
and you come up
and finally choke one of my girls
what i supposed to do just sit there
now i come and separate y'all jump on
you for choking my girl you got a gun i
ain't got no gun you blow my brains out
i don't know what you subject to do but
i got to protect her
i got to stop you from killing her
i got to stop anybody in the world from
doing something no huh some harm to it
so yeah i put my life on the line just
like they put their life on the line
i don't let nobody do nothing to them
you know i'm a man first
before your pin up or anything use a man
first
and i don't i don't i don't i don't
demand respect i command respect i'm
going to give it because i want you to
give it to me now if you're not giving
it to me because i command it then i
would demand it by any means necessary i
would demand it if i got to knock you
down you got to knock me down but you're
going to respect me
so yeah as far as that love now
you have to decide that if i put my life
on the line i would die for her then i
guess i was in love or loved or i love
them
you know me i had to care about them
you know i had to care about them
because i don't just
i don't just i just couldn't take any
and everybody couldn't be with me mark
you had to meet a certain criteria man
you understand i'm not going to take no
you know i'm not going to take no no no
no
anybody
uh uh just to be with me because you
know how to get money you know and and
it's not so much about flat backing
either
you can get a trick who who won't going
back to conversation you can get a trick
that that that that want to talk about
politics
you can get a trick that want to talk
about
taxes
uh that's why i teach my brothers how to
talk any level that this guy need to
talk on you understand anything about uh
a [ __ ] this [ __ ] that no i want you to
have a have a have an intelligent
conversation that you can have with this
guy that he can't get at home
you understand that's that's to me
that's the purpose of a prostitute you
getting what he can get from this hooker
then other than what he can get at home
or elsewhere
and it's real simple simplicity is the
key man you pay for this here and and 20
minutes half hour whatever you get get
that and going about your business you
ain't got to hear nothing that's the end
of that
you ain't gonna worry about taking a
shopping she talking about paying the
bills phone field gas bill the baby
needs diapers he ain't got to hear
nothing he ain't matter of fact he ain't
gotta hear nothing else from that chick
whatever
he done got his rocks off and rolled off
into the sunset
all right ron thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you very
fascinating talk thank you thank you
very much
you